you guys asked for it so here it is
whether it's Mario Brothers from Mario's
perspective or a girl gamer who seems to
be saying yeah size does matter it could
only mean one thing
episode 2 of IMG this week
BuzzFeed brought us some of the best
pictures of the moment a baseball hits
someone's face and then what the H how
about some baseball bats - speaking of
pictures taken at just the right time
here's the Google Streetview camera
splattered with bird poop on Sunset
Boulevard in LA if you want to explore
the bird poop as it happened there's a
link in the description to the actual
Street View image as well as every
single image in this show BAM right off
the bat I'm going to break the rules and
show some video clips because let's be
serious why the H not these clips were
featured on our lest this week and they
are the most unnecessary inventions
right now you're watching a grass
treadmill but they also had a machine
whose only function was to unplug itself
and a banana fan all right back to still
images but not that still I first saw
this image in a psychology class and I
revisited it this week because of Moe
illusions calm move your eyes around and
you will see the image rotate and move
seriously pause the video and keep
looking pretty freaky right moe
illusions also had this really cool
picture of Albert Einstein or is it step
away from your screen like 10 feet away
and the picture will magically transform
into Marilyn Monroe go back up close and
bam it's Albert Einstein again
maybe they're real maybe they're
photoshopped you guys tell me what you
think but they are MC escher styled
impossible structures made out of Legos
whatever it is they're really cool back
to BuzzFeed this collection is really
hot today and it is titled proof geeks
are sexy now we're going to transition
from sexy to tiny and slimy which in my
case is the same thing this picture is
super popular on NIDA Rama scientists
discovered the world's smallest ever
frog nope not that one smaller BAM there
it is look at that guy there were some
great suggestions over at facebook.com
slash Vsauce gaming Lucas submitted what
is both the funniest and the scariest
video game glitch mod acid trip whatever
you want to call it I've ever seen and
speaking of one-eyed monsters Isiah gave
us this fantastic Wow screen cap now
look at the tar and his title is the
patient
something tells me death flowers not
that good do you want something scary
Derek gave us this picture which I'm
guessing is the first Thanksgiving and
back to something sexy Kazi has
submitted this photoshop of Sylvanas on
the cover of Cosmopolitan it's an entire
Azeroth issue so be sure to read all of
the titles on it and just that fast it's
the end of episode 2 of IMG remember to
submit your favorite images of the week
over at facebook.com slash vsauce gaming
subscribe to vsauce for more see you
next week